what happens
inside the pipeline function in this
video
we'll look at what actually happens when
we use the pipeline function of the
transformers library
more specifically we'll look at the
sentiment analysis pipeline
and how it went from the two following
sentences to the positive
and negative labels with respective
scores
as we've seen in the pipeline
presentation there are three stages in
the pipeline
first we convert the row text to numbers
the model can make sense of
using a tokenizer then those numbers go
through the model which outputs the kits
finally the post-processing steps
transform those delegates into labels
and scores
let's look in details at those three
steps and how to replicate them using
the transformers library
beginning with the first stage
tokenization
the tokenization process has several
steps first
the text is split into small chunks
called tokens
they can be words part of words or
punctuation symbols
then the tokenizer will add some special
tokens if the model expects that
here the model used expect to see a list
token at the beginning
and a step token at the end of the
sentence to classify
lastly the tokenizer matches each token
to its unique id
in the vocabulary of the pre-trained
model to load such a tokenizer
the transformers library provides the
auto-tokenizer api
the most important method of this class
is from pre-trained
which will download and cache the
configuration and the vocabulary
associated to a given checkpoint
here the checkpoint used by default for
the sentiment analysis pipeline
is distilled based on case film tuned
ss2
english which is a bit of a mouthful we
instantiate the tokenizer associated
with a checkpoint
then feed it to the two sentences since
both two sentences are not of the same
size
we'll need to pad the shortest wand to
be able to build an array
this is done by the tokenizer with the
option padding equal to
with torquation equal to we ensure that
any sentence longer than the maximum the
model can handle
is truncated lastly the return tensors
option
tells the tokenizer to return the python
tensor
looking at the result we see we have a
dictionary with two keys
input ids contains the ids of both
sentences with zero where the padding is
applied
the second key a tension mask indicates
where padding has been applied so the
model does not pay attention to it
this is all what is inside the
tokenization step now let's have a look
at the second step
the model as for the tokenizer
there is an auto model api with a
form-free train method
it will download and catch the
configuration of the module as well as
the pre-trained weight
however the auto-model api will only
instantiate the body of the model
that is the part of the model that is
left once the retraining head is removed
it will output a high dimensional tensor
that is a representation of the
sentences passed
but which is not directly useful for a
classification problem
here the tensor has two sentences each
of 16 tokens
and the last dimension is the indent
size of our model
768. to get an output link to our
classification problem
we need to use the auto model for
sequence classification class
it works exactly as the automobile class
except that it will build
a model with a classification head there
is one auto class for each common nlp
task in the transformers library
here after giving our models the two
sentences
we get a tensor of size two by two one
result for each sentence
and for each possible label those
outputs are not probabilities yet
we can see they don't sum to one this is
because each model of the transformers
library
returns logits to make sense of those
logits
we need to dig into the third and last
step of the pipeline
post processing to convert logit into
probabilities
we need to apply a soft max layers to
them as we can see
this transforms them into positive
number that sum up to one
the last step is to know which of those
correspond to the positive or the
negative level
this is given by the id to label field
of the model config
the first probabilities index 0
correspond to the negative label
and the seconds index 1 correspond to
the positive level
this is how our classifier built with
the pipeline function picked those
labels
and computed both scores now that you
know how each step works
you can easily tweak them to your needs